i wanted to talk about psychic
signatures you know
signatures digital signatures that just
get you in any door right that's the
idea it's called psychopath it's out
it's after doctor who isn't it right so
it's been a while since i've watched
doctor who but the idea is that doctor
who keeps showing people this blank
piece of paper and it's psychic paper
which means that they see some
identification that means something to
them and that's the idea you provide a
signature
that is invalid but the java
implementation thinks it's valid and
lets it in right and that's a really
really big problem
a security researcher called neil madden
has
disclosed the vulnerability in some of
the implementations of java that is very
very serious
it basically allows you to approach a
website with a fake signature and be let
straight in right and you know these are
used for things like one-time
authentication mechanisms they're used
for um java web tokens lots of reasons
to be using this kind of technology
there's nothing wrong with it but if
it's not implemented correctly can cause
a real problem this was a bug introduced
in java 15 and has existed up to java 18
and it's now been patched right so if
you run any kind of java server you need
to be patching really really quite
quickly this is quite a serious serious
bug it was introduced when they ported
the code from c plus plus to java and
essentially did a slightly botched
implementation where they didn't perform
some of the necessary checks in the
elliptic curve digital signature
algorithm right that's the algorithm at
play here so it's the elliptic curve
digital signature algorithm now we've
done elliptic curves before very very
briefly just to remind everyone your
elliptic curve on a set of real numbers
would look something like this it looks
slightly different when you're modulo
some large prime and the idea is that
you can add points together on this
curve so you can take a point here let's
say g
and then you can add g to itself to
itself again to itself again and end up
somewhere over here with point a
times by g so that's g plus g plus g
plus g a times and the the interesting
thing about elliptic curve is when you
do this it's very difficult to say what
a was right if i say here's a g
here's g
what was a you don't know right and so a
can be my private key an elliptic curve
dsa is based around this idea right i
could give you a message and you could
use your private key to sign that
message and send me back a signature and
then i could look at the message i could
look at the signature and i could go yep
or no
that's the idea we'll look at elliptic
curve dsa sort of a little brief
overview right we're not going to prove
any mathematics here today um but
just so we can talk about what the
actual implementation
bag in java is and then we can talk
about how that actually manifests itself
if someone was actually attacking a
system we're going to use two people
having a conversation
cryptographically
got to be alice and bob right let's not
i'm not going to be that person to step
step outside the mold um right now bob
is the one that's going to be signing
something to alice so bob has previously
calculated a private and a public key
right so he calculates a private key b
which is a random integer right and he
also has a curve right the curve says he
has a curve let's call the curve c big c
and he has n which is his number of
points on a curve now different letters
will be used by different you know if
you've got a look on the wikipedia page
for this they'll use n but if you look
in textbooks they might use q it's not
we're just i'm going to try and be as
consistent as i can on this piece of
paper right so bob calculates an integer
private value b
and then he calculates a public key
which is the generator point
on this curve times by b so capital b
is b g right capital means on the curve
does it um yeah so this would be a this
would be a curve point yeah capitals on
the curve one of the reasons elliptic
curves get a little bit confusing is
because often your private keys and some
of your values are integers and some of
them are points on the curve so g here
is a point on the curve and this b
multiple of g is a point on the curve b
is obviously just an integer actually
this video is not really about dsa in
some sense so i you know we're not going
to go too much in detail about what
everything everything does exactly right
and i'm going to skip over some details
so now let's imagine that alice wants
bob to sign a message so maybe alice
sends bob a message
m right now this message you know could
be a challenge token it could be you
know some documents you need signing it
doesn't really matter for this example
what bob's going to do is now generate a
signature for this message he's going to
first calculate an intermediate value of
the message which is going to hash the
message right into a shortened form
that's z then he's going to choose a
random k
right and that random k is what we call
an ephemeral key we talked about this a
bit with diffie-hellman but k
essentially makes this signature
probabilistic it makes it different each
time bob calculates its signature it's
actually extremely important that k is
random each time and different each time
now this is where the math starts coming
in right we're going to calculate r
right this is the first half of our
signature r
is k times by the generator point so
that's a point on the curve and then
you're just going to take
the x
uh component now what i've done there is
i've mixed mathematical notation with
programming notation and i'm going to
say here no more about that that's
absolutely fine as far as i'm concerned
right and then you calculate the second
part of signature s
right which is k to the minus one so
then the multiplicative inverse of k
multiplied by z plus
r times b and for those who are not
mathematically minded the multiplicative
inverse is one over that is it well it's
so yeah yeah very good very good
question so in normal maths yes right if
you wanted to multiply the
multiplicative inverse of x is one over
x
when you're doing modulo n which is what
we're doing on this elliptic curve you
actually have to calculate the
multiplicative inverse it will just be
some other number between one and n
minus one and you could use the extended
euclidean album to do that you can use
uh fermat's theorem to do that um
there's a few ways of calculating this
but it's not immediately obvious what it
is right you can't just say oh it's this
you know you have to we have to
calculate it but we're not going to
worry about that too much bob will then
respond this is it he's finished right
bob will then respond with a met with
the message m yeah i mean maybe alice
already knows it doesn't he said it and
the signature
r
s and this is where alice now has to
verify this signature so we did a video
on digital signatures already but
in this case it's not too difficult for
alice to verify so first of all she
needs to check that r and s
are in the range
one to n minus one right so then she
needs to check that
r and s are both at least one and less
than or equal to n minus one
all right then she's going to calculate
the intermediate hash value of the
message again
all right
and then she's going to calculate a
couple of equations so the first one is
u1
is equal to z times by
s to the minus one
mod n right now it's not important
actually to understand this attack to
understand follow exactly what this math
is doing right because we're going to
talk about the problems that the java
implementation has u2 is equal to r
times s to the minus 1
mod n again right everything's mod n so
again we'd use the same algorithm we
used for k minus 1 on s minus 1 to get
the multiplicative inverse of s and then
this is the actual test alice needs to
check that r is equal to or congruent to
u1 times by the generator point g
plus u2
times by bob's public key capital b
and then just the x coordinate for those
of you thinking well how does that work
right
that involves the proof okay it's very
very clever but we won't write that out
because that's not really what this
video is about alice's process of
verifying the signature basically if she
takes m and the pair the signature pair
r and s and calculates this equation and
if the two sides match then this is
sorry this is mod n
and mods that thing where it's a bit
like a clock face yeah it's a clock face
so if you divide by n and you take the
remainder right so n mod n is back to
zero again right and n plus one mod n is
one you know um now
just just to not completely skip over
what ecdsa is doing here
how does alice know that bob signed this
message right well basically because the
fact that this works means that bob must
have been in control of the private key
b right because it was used as part of
this equation the other thing is that u1
and u2 include both parts of the
signature and the hash of the message so
it's also checking that the signature
matches the message which is very very
important so alice knows if this is true
if the left hand side equals the right
hand side alice knows that not only does
this signature match this message but
also it was bob that signed it right as
long as no one's stolen bob's private
key it's a different video for a
different time
all right now what's wrong with the java
implementation well one of the problems
with ecdsa that you have to be careful
if you're implementing it
is for example i mentioned you have to
choose a random k you can't choose a
cave that's been used before right so
actually
a truly random k could be a bit risky
because you might accidentally generate
the same one twice so sometimes they
have ways of deterministically
generating k such that you can be
absolutely sure you never repeat it
right
another big problem is if you don't do
this check in here i'm going to i'm
going to put this in red this is very
important right but you check this
if r and s are not in the range one to n
minus one you can't guarantee the
security of this scheme in this
particular attack
the issue is that java doesn't check but
rns are both not zero
right that's a real problem so let's
work through what would happen if r and
s was zero well the hash comes out
exactly the same z is the hash of m
right u1 is that hash multiplied by the
multiplicative inverse of s which is
zero multiplied versus zero now that
that mathematically doesn't actually
exist but
it does in this case because the java
implementation happens to just spit zero
back out at you right so
it is z times zero is zero right u2
is r which is zero times by s minus one
which is zero
is zero all right so we've got zero and
zero and zero times g plus zero times u
both of those are unfortunately the
point of infinity which is essentially
zero on this curve the x coordinate of
that is zero
it's zero equals zero question mark and
that's the test that alice will perform
to decide whether this signature is
valid and it is because zero does indeed
equal zero as far as i can see i can see
i haven't noticed anything wrong with
that um
so let's talk a bit about
you know let's let's move away from the
map and let's talk a little bit about
what practically this means right
essentially this is an implementation
bug this is very clearly defined in the
spec that you make this test you also
have to check that this is not the point
of infinity right there's two checks
that you have to make here and they have
not been made so as you say this is
implementation so that basically means
that the theory sounds but it's not
being put into practice right what's the
implication here what actually happens
in reality it's it's really serious
right this kind of technique is used all
over the place on the web but it's used
in a couple of core authentication
mechanisms which is where this is the
real problem like immediately right it's
a problem everywhere things like banks
well yeah it could be used by banks to
you know verify messages from other
banks for example you don't want a
situation where a bank can send a
transaction signed by xeros and it be
accepted and you know i mean maybe he's
an attacker i might quite like that
um but you know another example is one
of these you know one-time um password
or login two-factor authentication
devices so for example i have one um one
of these ubi keys like there are lots of
devices like this
and what they often will do is they will
respond to a challenge from the server
by signing something with the private
key using elliptic curve dsa so suppose
there's a server here
and here's me with my key
that's the world's worst key isn't it
and what happens is the server sends a
challenge
challenge
m
and i
sign that challenge using elliptic curve
dsa
and i send back m
and r s right now the server will verify
against my public key and that would
have been the first time i registered my
device so maybe at some point i logged
on to the system and said i'd like to
register one of these devices i plugged
it in and it went great your device is
registered you can now use it for
two-factor authentication what will then
happen is the server will verify this
signature against the challenge message
and check whether it's correct right now
the reason it has to send a challenge
message is because of course otherwise i
could just send this all the time right
if it always sent the same message like
sign the number five then everyone will
just get a copy of that valid signature
and just send it on and pretend to be me
so it has to be random each time but the
issue here is that an attacker can just
send m
zero zero right and if this server is
implemented in java versions 15 to 18 it
will go yep brilliant and let and let
you log in right so literally
you just take this and you just write
zero
zero and then you can just start waving
your way through different different
servers right and no no questions asked
so you know if you're running a java
server i can't stress enough that you
really need to be patching it
um before this video began but really
get on with it now
3g plus g
would be it goes along here like this
intersects the curve somewhere else
flips over and it's over here so this is
4g now we won't look at it anymore right
the actual formula for this is just
mathematics to do with line and when
that space what it's doing is it's
looking for extra areas where it can add
the nodes to build that graph up